[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
end game class as always my name is
caleb denby
and today i am going to be taking you
through rook end games
and we are gonna get into the
nitty-gritty tonight we are going to
look
at the most basic rook in games which
are of course you know slightly more
complicated than rook versus rook
but rook and pawn versus rook i want to
start
from the ground up here and work to give
you guys a good
theoretical knowledge of what's actually
going on in these positions
and things to look for in your own games
i do want to say i used as
a reference for this lecture the
wonderful dvoretsky's end game
manual that is of course sort of the
end-all be-all
for all things end games and it's no
different for for these rook end games
so if you guys want a really good
comprehensive manual that is definitely
the book i recommend i think it's the
book everybody recommends
it's just um comprehensive is is the
word for it
so let's jump into it hopefully i can
sort of take a lot of this information
and make it a little bit more digestible
than doveretsky did you know a common
complaint of that book is that
it is sort of you know hard to get
through
it's difficult stuff uh to start with
though
we are starting with this position with
white to move
and many of you are probably familiar
with this position it
does have a name that name is the lucena
position
however there may be more going on here
than you were first
taught so white to move and win is a
pretty common puzzle and
i'll give it to you here so wait to move
and win
what does the chat room think uh
i'm not even going to wait for them to
answer because i know many people
already know
of course the loose sena position the
main idea everyone is taught
is that you build a bridge with the rook
to give your king's safety
shelter from checks in order to promote
the pawn what does that actually look
like
well it starts with the key move rook to
g1
check black now has two options
black can go to f6 or retreat to the h
file
king f6 optically looks like a good move
but after king f8 the king is actually
blocking this rook from interfering with
the white king
and white is able to promote on the next
turn and win without question
so king h7 works a bit better
now of course white would love to get
out of the way of this pawn
with the king in order to allow it to
promote but
if you try it then you're going to get
checked into oblivion
and won't be able to do anything but
come back
to the e8 square
so of course what's the winning idea
here for white well you build a bridge
with the move rook g4 how does this work
well now after black moves you come to
f7
get checked checked and after
check you have an improvement you no
longer have to repeat forever and ever
and ever
you can step to e5 when you are not
getting skewered you can
block the check with the rook the rook
has bridged the gap
i actually never understood the bridge
metaphor i don't know how this is a
bridge at all
it's more of a blocker but nonetheless
this is the winning technique that many
people learn right off the bat
so it may surprise you to learn jumping
back to the original position
that white has more than one way to win
in this position
this building a bridge technique is
definitely a great way to do it it
i think is even the fastest way to do it
but it is very very useful to understand
that white can win this end game in
other ways you don't necessarily have to
build a bridge so who can tell me the
other winning ideas here besides for
building a bridge
this is where you know we we really get
into it here
this is where we really get into it
and okay i don't know
if i can actually ask the chat room um
as of you know live streaming and
recording this youtube is experiencing
some difficulties sort of worldwide
um you know hopefully the company
doesn't go under i get the feeling
google will figure out the details
but uh for the moment i'm sort of flying
without a chat room here
so the other wins well it may surprise
you to learn
that of course starting with rook g1
check is always going to be good we want
to force the king away
king f6 is trivial as we said king h7
white now has two other winning ideas
besides for the move
rook g4 uh what ideas are those
well surprisingly rook e1 and rook d1
are both easily winning for white and
that may not be what you expect at first
glance
so what's the idea well let's start with
rook
e1 this one is i think a little bit
simpler
if black tries to get the king back into
the game we just simply run away with
our king
and e8 is simply impossible to stop
and when you see this on the board it
looks sort of obvious
and honestly i'm not sure why we're
teaching people to build bridges
when this is just so easy you play
rookie one you move the king out of the
way and then you promote the pawn
of course it is not quite as fast
because your king is going to get
checked around a little bit
but the king can simply run away and
when the checks run
outs okay eights we're going to promote
the pawn
or alternatively if black tries this of
course we queen right away
and the one thing to look out for is
probably you should
not be playing like this and allowing
the black rook in front of the pawn
but rookie one is an easy way to win
when black has no
defensive ideas here if you check from
this side of the board
king e6 is fine but also
if you don't like fancy stuff like king
e6 just running up the board is is gonna
win the game as well there's no way to
stop ea queen
so that is a second way to win this
position now why is that useful to know
well oftentimes you're not going to get
this ideal lucent position
just sort of out of nowhere and it may
be achievable
to get one of these other wins the these
rookie one type positions or rook d1
type of positions so
i do think it is really good to know
these alternate ideas
or if you get some funny looking
position where you think the lucina
idea of building the bridge might work
but you're not sure
this is a good fallback for that sort of
thing
now remember rookie one isn't the only
way to win rook
d1 is also a good move and actually here
rook d1 is is also winning as well rook
e1 i don't think quite gets the job done
because here um black
is well i i guess actually this this
does work immediately
but uh it is simpler with the king on h7
but
okay rook d1 immediately is also going
to be winning why is that well let's say
rook a8 check the the only idea here is
for black to start checking
the white king can simply leave and
after rook a7 check
king e6 or k6 check now we can block
this check with rook d6
uh we have to stop the pawn from
promoting now so rook a8
but rook d8 and again white is able to
queen by force
there's three different completely
unique
unique ideas uh in order to win the
loose center position
and uh at least for myself up until
recently
i really only knew building a bridge
right and and so i hope it's
you know clear to you guys that's the
lucena position is
is not some sort of wild idea where you
have this strange geometry where you can
go rook g4 and your rook is just far
enough away from the black king that it
works
and close enough to the white king that
it works there's actually multiple ways
to win this position
and some of these you may even find
easier than the lucena
so all in all this position we have the
white king in front of the pawn
the pawn on the seventh rank that's very
important
this position is winning for white if it
is white to move
with either uh these two ideas or
the the rook g4 idea also with the
caveat
of course checking first is always going
to be useful because king f6 never works
due to king f8 so let's move on now to
the same position
but with the board flipped here we have
black
to move and so i'm going to introduce
the first
and probably the most robust defensive
idea for
black so black to move is white still
winning this position
or is it a draw go ahead pause the video
at home if you want to try to figure it
out for yourself
but i am going to reveal the answer here
it is in fact a draw why is it a draw
well it's a draw due to something known
as the short
side defense this king is on the quote
short side of the board and because of
that
there is enough space for this rook to
interfere with this king
along these rank checks how much space
is enough space well believe it or not
black has just
enough space here in three files three
files is the magic number
for black to be able to check the white
king and that's what black has here
why three files well we'll move on to
that in a second but first
let's examine why exactly this is a draw
we go rook a8 check king has one legal
move
we go rook a7 check the king can now
come up
or down it doesn't really matter but at
the end of the day
this is why three files is important the
king cannot interfere with the rook
and defend the pawn at the same time
it's just a little
bit too far away if the king tries to
leave the pawn
we can check again and continue checking
it can get super far away then rook a8
is going to be fine as well as you know
just continuing to check
is not going to do us any harm notably
if white ever thinks he's going to block
a check
simplest is just to capture and king f7
right
so this is the you know short side
defense
i don't know if i'm actually in love
with this name that the chess world has
adopted
because it involves checking from the
long side and having your king on the
short side
so rather than try to remember a name
and then
try to associate the name with the
position try and remember the idea
uh don't remember the name remember the
idea the idea is to check
from the side and give your rook enough
space to to check the king
now what happens if we have only two
files
so the exact same position but the rook
is on b2
rather than a2 well now the idea isn't
going to work
for black we can check on b8 king d7
check king d6 check and now
king to c7 and it's
sort of interesting to draw um some
comparisons
between this idea with three files being
enough for black to
check and two being too little to the
actual building a bridge
idea so just to compare
let's say instead black goes here and we
need to build a bridge
how do we go about doing that well rook
g1 check
king h7 rook g4
pass here and notably there
are two quote lines
in this case ranks rather than files
between the king and the rook
and thus the rook can interpose it's the
same sort of idea
just with the colors kind of reversed
okay so what's the point of the story
point of the story is three files enough
for a draw
thanks to these checks two files not
enough
the king can interfere with the rook and
the rook cannot maintain its attack on
the pawn just to continue
rookie six of course king d7 and this
will be winning the game okay so
once again why is it called the short
side defense well it's
usually called this because the king
belongs on the short side what happens
if the king is on the long side
well then uh of course
i should of course define my terms here
long side meaning the sign with
more files on the side of the pawn four
vials
four files versus three in this case
well with the king on the long side
there's never enough space
two files is the maximum and we know
that two files isn't enough
so black is losing this position
king here and the game is over
so that is pretty much everything there
is to say
about these positions where white has
the king on e8
and the pawn on e7 so let us
move along now to the you know the the
tough part of the lecture
um these sort of four ideas three ideas
uh are not too difficult to learn and
keep in mind
but life does get more complicated when
you move this pawn back
to the sixth rank rather than the
seventh rank in fact they get
significantly more complicated so of
course
black's drawing ideas are sort of
amplified
the further back the pawn gets right
because it takes quite a lot longer
to get to one of these winning positions
with the king in front of the pawn
and black can always sort of angle for
one of these draws
right with this sort of long side
checking idea
so let's take a look at this position
here
so here we have the pawn on the sixth
rank and we actually have the king
sort of in front of the pawn for black
white of course
is threatening checkmate here does
anybody know the drawing idea
here if you do or if you want to try to
find it for yourself
go ahead pause the video and try to take
a look here
if not of course the idea is to check
from
behind it's very very similar
to the idea we saw in this position
where we check the king from the side
because
the king has no shelter right the king
cannot hide behind this pawn
because our king is in the way over here
now rather than checking from the side
the point is the king has no shelter in
front of the pawn
and so we can check the king from behind
we go rook f1 check
and the game is going to be a draw the
king moves check
king d6 check here check
uh and it's it's just going to be a draw
i want to mention by the way
you know if you think that this idea of
you know bridge building is going to
save you
uh here for example if if black if you
had this position instead
again check here check building a bridge
doesn't work when our king is in front
of the pawn
because again we can just trade trade
the rooks get the king in front of the
pawn with
a trivial draw so this
is the main drawing idea for black
you know in the ideal scenario this is
sort of all you need
for black to draw the game against a
pawn on the sixth rank you need your
king
somewhat in front of the pawn and you
need to check from behind
of course life is not always that
simple oftentimes it's very difficult to
get this checking from behind
uh you know achieved in your games that
being said
really really important crucial idea to
keep in mind
checking the king from behind when the
king cannot shelter in front of the pawn
all right let us keep moving here
the next idea i want to introduce is the
idea
of passive defense so here what do i
mean by passive defense
well rather than have the rook on an
active square
like b1 for example where it can check
the king from behind
with the same drawing idea that we just
saw in this case
something has gone wrong for black and
the rook has been relegated
to the eighth rank uh
so um
i'm getting word that exactly one person
in the chat can see the stream and he
has now been delegated
as the play-by-play so he will be
relaying to the chat
all of the positions and ideas in real
time see how that goes for peter
but uh okay what's going on here
well this is passive defense why is it
passive defense well we can't
actively check the king but black isn't
out of it just yet this rook
on the eighth rank is preventing
checkmate in preventing this pawn from
queening
so is this winning for white or not
well thanks to the fact that this is a
night pawn
meaning starting on uh meaning it's on
the file that the knights start on
black is actually able to draw this
position
why is that well we'll see that white
would have another resource
if the pawn was one step over but for
the moment the best we can do
is check this king around and at the end
of the day
we're not going to make any progress if
we ever try moving the king around
black can simply pass as well there's no
way to make progress here
no matter what you do if you push this
pawn forward well actually in this case
i've lost the game for white which is
pretty impressive
but if you push this pawn forward under
different circumstances
let's say here i'm always able to check
your king away
and in fact i don't even have to i can
just stay passive
against this night pawn forever and ever
and ever although this is probably
the the simplest here when white's
pieces are now tied down
simply no way to make progress uh with
the knight pawn
against this passive defense with the
rook on the eighth rank
now does that story change with a
bishop's pawn
of course a pawn on the file that the
bishops
begin on which is not there but in fact
there
very accurate circle drawing by me
and the answer is white actually has an
extra resource in this case
what resource is that well thanks to the
addition of an
extra file on this side of the board
white is just able to win the game
how does that work well it works with
this idea of checking the king
now in the previous example we saw king
f8 rook f7
and white had to come back to a7 because
there was simply nothing to do
right with with the knight pawn there
was nothing to do fortunately for white
that is not the case here and after rook
g7 check
king f8 or h8 either way
rook h7 is going to be playable and
after king back to g8
stopping rook h8 check of course i
should mention that that's the big idea
of rook h7
if black passes then rookie jade is mate
so king g8 trying to stop that white has
the critical winning move here
of pawn to f7 check and now the end
is here for black white is able to
capture this rook on b8
will queen next it is up two major
pieces now
impressive stuff so with a bishop's pawn
then this passive defense is not enough
and black
must go after this checking from behind
or is that the case is there one more
surprise draw that black has against the
bishop's pawn
and it turns out there is um this one
was pretty surprising to me when i first
learned about it
and we'll see if it surprises you guys
as well
so this position white to play here
let's say white plays the best winning
try which is rook
a1 you go rook a1 you try to check mate
the king
now black to move should you play the
move
rook b8 yes or no
tell me tell me tell me tell me yes or
no rook b8
peter peter are you with us peter peter
are you still watching
ah if peter's not watching then nobody's
watching that's tough
okay so you guys at home tell me is rook
b8 good enough
of course the answer is no why is
rick b8 not good enough well this is the
passive defense
and rook a7 is going to be winning with
the exact same idea
that we've just seen king f8 rook here
um by the way is this working no okay
so rook h7 i was worried my passing was
inaccurate in general
whenever you're passing in these end
games i think it's better to
stay opposite the king rather than go
directly in front of the pawn
but it doesn't matter here so king f8
rook h7 and this winning idea
that we've seen before would come into
play so
clearly you know this is it black is
black is just dead here rook a1 is a
great move
and black will lose the game that being
said of course
that's not true so go ahead pause the
video here
if you want to try to find the solution
otherwise
here it is the key move in this position
is of course
rook g7 check the surprise drawing idea
is going to be good enough for black
here what's the point
well you can't capture this due to the
rule of stalemate
and black is is surprisingly drawing the
game the best try is king f5
but now of course what should we do to
draw this position
go ahead and try to figure it out for
yourself the idea is to switch
not to the same defense which actually
is enough to draw but is
a bit harder instead you want to start
checking
from behind whenever possible check the
king from behind
that's the surefire draw and you're not
going to lose the game if you managed
to to start doing this when there's no
shelter for the king
so rook g2 and white can't agree to a
draw here
nothing to do in this position
okay for example king e6 rookie two
check
and again no shelter at all something
like rook f1
trying to stop this just go king f7 and
once again a simple draw for black so
that pretty much covers these positions
where the black king is in front of the
pawn and the pawn is on the sixth rank
so let's sort of put them into general
categories here
we have all of the positions where the
black king is in front of the pawn
and we can check from behind those are
all going to be drawn
every time you check from behind going
to be a draw with the pawn on the sixth
rank and the king in front
we have all of the positions where black
is passively defending
with the rook on the eighth rank these
are going to be
drawn if the pawn is on the knights file
and potentially losing if the pawn is on
the bishop's file you can't defend
passively
with this rook on b8
now we have this one surprise draw
example
where we can have this nice little
resource of rook
g7 check in this case with the stalemate
idea
and i do want to mention what happens
if for example in this position
we have the same position but with the
king on
this side of the board what's going on
here
this is sort of the last thing to talk
about with the black king
in front of the pawn
what's going on here
and peter is doing his job trying to
relay the information and the positions
to the chat
but uh mixed results i think
so uh of course this position is also
going to be a draw
why is that well if you're paying
attention you should always be looking
for opportunities
to start checking from behind and black
is able to do that here
how so well rook b6 check forces the
king back
we're no longer under the threat of
checkmate and we go rook b1
and the king is lacking shelter once
again
black is able to prevail with this idea
so white's best try of course is to have
this king
on again the short side of the pawn like
we've talked about before
okay so let's move on to what uh makes
things
even more complicated here so we have
the positions with the black king in
front of the pawn
now let's take a look at what happens if
the white king
is in front of the pawn and this is
going to be
a bit more complex so
with the white kingdom in front of the
pawn is all hope lost
for black yes or no well
let's start by looking at this position
here black to move is there any
possible way to draw this game if you
want to try to figure it out for
yourself at home
again i would encourage you to pause the
video as the youtube outage is making
local news good good to hear
i don't know what sort of voodoo
peter peterson has to to keep the stream
alive
but uh kudos to him finding the path
through
jeff says this is the lucena right and
he would be wrong
the lucena position is i think taught in
a very deceptive manner
where people just start assuming king's
in front of the pawn
i'm going to put the pawn here the king
here and win the game
and in a perfect world that's exactly
what you would do
but black does have this nice defensive
idea
of again checking from the long side of
the board we have this three file
separation
and it turns out in this case 2 rook a7
is going to be enough to draw
i should mention that rook a7 would be a
trivial draw
if the rook were over here on f2
because again it's the same situation
where the black white king just has
absolutely no shelter
but with the rook on d2 it actually
still is going to be enough to draw
what's the idea well if the white king
just starts moving around
it's the same story that we've seen
before we just keep checking this guy
if rook here we step
pretty much anywhere besides rook a7 or
k7 would lose to this
but i'm going to introduce the key
square in a moment
the best try for white is rook d7
when the best way to draw is to go rook
a8
as is the case in that line i just
showed with king d6
where for some reason i put the king
here before doing this right
rook a8 is always the square you want to
step to
why is that well let's take a look rook
a8
and how can white try to win this
position
well white of course is looking to get
the pawn
to the seventh rank and sort of
interfere with this rook's defense of it
somehow so that the only real way to try
to win
is to go king d6 with a check actually
why is this the only way to try to win
if you go rook d8 i'm going to go over a
k7 check
if you go king 8 i'm going to go king f6
this pawn is indefensible rook d6
i check and take this guy so only way to
try to win
of course by the way this would repeat
only way to win
is with king 2 d6 check
and black to move and draw here is
actually not so hard you just bring the
king to f6
try to challenge this pawn now if e7
we can simply go rook e8 and there's no
way to make progress here
with uh with white you can go rook a7
king f7 rook b7
pass pass pass
and the game is eventually going to end
go here
rookie 8 doesn't matter um
if you don't don't like that way of
drawing no need to worry you can also
just go rook a6 check and king f7
any of these moves are going to draw the
game so it does turn out that this sort
of
uh checking from this long side
is going to be a good drawing idea for
black in almost every case
so if you do find yourself in one of
these technical end games
my advice to you put your king on the
short side of the pawn
put your rook on the long side of the
pawn and odds are you might stumble into
some
sort of draw that being said
we are looking at actually all the
specifics here so if you can manage to
remember all this
then you will be well equipped for any
situation
so now the question is what's going on
in this position this position should
look pretty familiar to you
all i've done is actually flip the board
so white to move here there are actually
two methods
to win the game so see if you can find
either one first of all and then we're
gonna talk
a little bit more about the way i want
you to win
okay so uh if you haven't found it go
ahead pause the video
if so sorry just checking back in on the
chat
uh if you haven't found it go ahead and
pause the video
if you have or just want to know the
answer of course the simple way to win
this
is just to go rook g2 check you force
the king away
something like king h7 will happen and
now king f7 is going to be simple enough
work f1 check king eights rookie one
e7 and white has achieved the lucena
position
and we'll be able to win with any of
those winning ideas that we talked about
earlier
so that's the easy way to win but let me
ask you
what the evaluation of the position is
after
king to e8 is black
able to draw this position
yes or no
is black able to draw this position
chess king says no why not
what's the winning idea
what is the winning idea here
so first of all let's take a look at the
drawing idea
uh king f6 looks reasonably tempting
to start with and you can in fact start
with it and then of course
e7 is going to be white's best try
so what is black's idea black's idea is
sort of always
to check from the long side of the board
now what's the difference between this
and the draw that we just saw
well of course the pieces are shifted up
a file this is why it's useful
to realize this is a winning idea from
the lucena position
with the king in front of the pawn like
that now we can go rook d8 and block
this check
after rook a7 making a threat
can go rook d6 check forcing the king
back
and now it is not so easy to just
build a bridge right away but we can
just go rook back to d1
with a winning idea that we've seen
earlier
also notably we can go rook e6 with a
winning idea
that we've seen earlier which is after
check
we move the king
and queen r pawn or
of course run over this way
with the same idea where takes e6 is of
course
winning with the king blocked out so
this position is actually a bit tougher
for black to draw and in fact the
position is just going to be winning for
white if we go rookie check first still
rook d8 will come
rook a1 still e7 and again
we're always going to be winning this
position thanks to our winning idea
of rook d1 when we can escape with our
king
useful to understand this other idea to
win the position with white
okay now we've gone through
most of the ideas with the pawn on the
sixth rank i think these
are really the most important ideas to
take away
from this lecture so we are finally
finally finally arriving
at the other position that many of you
have probably heard of
and that of course is going to be
philidor's position
so let's take a look here fiddler's
position involves
many many many of the ideas with the
pawn on the sixth rank
but of course occurs when the pawn
itself is not yet on the sixth rank but
the pawn on the fifth rank
and the king on the fifth rank as well
so it's important to understand these
ideas with the pawn on the sixth rank
before moving on to learning the
philidor's position at least
in my opinion so what is the drawing
idea here for black i'm sure many people
in the chat room are familiar with it
but go ahead and tell me black to move
and draw the game what's the easiest way
to do it
and yeah chess king is well prepared as
always
so the the easy way to draw the
philidor's position is
if you can you get the rook to the sixth
rank if you get the rook to the sixth
rank you're always
going to be able to draw um why are you
always
going to be able to draw well now you
are cutting the king off from the sixth
rank
and we take advantage of a principle
that we learned
earlier on in the lecture what principle
is that
well if the pawn moves to the sixth rank
we've got our king
in front of the pawn and we can rely on
what
drawing technique chat room what drawing
technique can we rely on
peter peterson has it the drawing
technique of checking
from behind so we get rid of the king's
shelter
then we drop our rook back to b1 and
it's exactly what we've seen before
no way to make progress with white is
going to get checked
into oblivion and that is the basic
idea of philodor's position
this is probably where many people sort
of end their study
of philidors they say okay put my king
in front of the pawn
put the rook on the sixth rank and i
can't lose perfect
but of course reality often ends up
being
a little bit messier than that so let's
take a look
at a slightly different position
uh oh that king moved so starting with
the king
not on f5 but on f6 what is the
evaluation
of this position can black draw or is
white winning
can black draw or is white winning
sami says to draw with rook e1
interesting idea
what is the points what is the point
after king e6
for example
so of course the thing to avoid is
falling into the trap that i think many
beginners do
where they say ah this is philidor's
position i put the rook on the sixth
rank and then i can't lose
uh of course this is going to be bet
with e6 when your rook is not
in position to check from behind you're
now facing a back rank mate threat
you have to go rook b8 but the bad news
is
passive defense does not work
when the pawn is not a night pawn rook
h7 and you would lose the game
so of course the idea is in fact rook
e1 but i have yet to see someone in the
chat
tell me why this is drawing after king
e6
it doesn't really look like it's drawing
to my eyes this looks pretty scary looks
pretty scary
chess king says king f8 now which okay
sure you're under the threat of
checkmate king f8
but but why is why does this draw what
is stopping white from just advancing
this pawn up the board
what's stopping white from advancing up
the board
peter peterson also says rook d1 to stop
the checkmate
but this isn't actually good enough if
you go rook d1
i can even just check
take take king f7 and promote my pawn
ah sammy even has the name of the method
which is not something that i remembered
so of course king f8 is a good idea now
why is king f8 a better idea than king
d8
you know just optics why go king f8 and
not king d8
why not this is this is your big test
chat room we're incorporating many many
many ideas
what's so good about f8 compared to d8
huh
do we just hate hate the d file and yeah
the the general idea
is that you always with either side
really
want your king on the short side of the
board why do you want your king on the
short side
because it's easier to stop checks from
the short side of the board which is why
king of fate is better move
it's worth noting though that king d8
does also draw the game
with the exact same idea that being said
let's see the idea before we look at the
alternate idea so
king f8 is the point now how does white
make progress if something like king d6
you just get checked back no progress
made but rook back to e1
now if rook a8 check this is seemingly
the way to make progress
but after king g7 king d6 what is the
drawing move
here what is the drawing move here
black to move and draw the game
and yeah chess king has it it's
definitely not the move
rook d1 check what's different well here
if the king steps to the d file it
cannot step to e7 or e8
why not well because we have the move
rook d
or well because our king is here but
after rook a check king g7 king d6
we don't have that kind of luxury
unfortunately if we check
on rook d1 now king e7 and believe it or
not
black is losing this position why is
black losing
because white very cleverly has his rook
placed on the a
file why does that matter because we
can't
go for any long side defense now we're
just too close
to the king so after rook b1
then e6 rook b7 check
and now king d6
to win the game notably not king e8
allowing king f6 but king d6
rook b6 check king d7 rook b7 check
and now king c6 and the rook has run out
of squares so
this basically is is to say
that this position is losing for black
thanks
to the fact that the king has the e7
square so the only way to draw is what
chess king recommended
which is this move king f7
why does this draw well this is the
critical point of this rook
on e1 you are preventing this pawn from
advancing to the sixth rank
using your two pieces to control it
okay there's one more winning idea for
white
one more winning idea for white that you
have to take a look at
and i'm actually going to quickly set up
another position
for you guys to take a look at that that
winning idea
but first of all i want to ask you sort
of a follow-up question which is
let's say this is our starting position
if i can
triangulate somehow it turns out i can't
triangulate okay
let's say this is our starting position
is white able to win if we follow down
the same path rookie 1 king e6
king f8 rook b8 check
king g7 king d6 and then let's say
your opponent is a fool and they don't
know the king f7 idea
okay and they just naively check you is
white winning here
in this position with the rook on b8
rather than a8
what do we think
and yes sammy is the rook endgame
aficionado
and the winning idea is of course to
come to the a1 square
when we have three files of separation
and are drawing the game
no progress to be made here for whites
why is that
well it's because you can't leave your
pawn
this is always a draw thanks to this
okay one more question
and sammy is asking the right question
here
rook f1 check why does this move lose
well the answer of course is king e6
only move
now if we try uh the same idea king f8
no time to go rookie one because the
checkmate is threatened
now rookie a check king g7 king d6
and you can't stop the pawn from getting
to e6
you just can't stop the pawn from
getting the e6
and then we've seen this before we've
seen this before
only two files separating king and rook
so once again
white is going to be winning now
one more question for you guys let's
take this position
and actually move it over to files
okay what is going on in
this position
what is going on here should black play
rook to g1 or should black not
play rook to g1
right all we did move the kings and the
pawn
over two files
and yeah chess king has the right idea
if you have the black side of this
of course of course of course you
recognize that this is a knight pawn
and you go rook b8 we've seen the pass
with defense
and this is going to be the draw for
black
now that being said let's say you're on
the white side of things and your
opponent thinks they're very clever
they know this philidor defending idea
with rook
g1 what is the evaluation
of this position is white winning
or is this drawing idea somehow
different
let's say you have the white pieces
can you win this position
jeff says no scott says not
savage gamer plays says rook g7 check
articum says winning when it comes to
kg3 winning
what's the winning idea what's the
winning idea
i'll give you a hint it is winning it is
in fact
winning
so let's talk about what's not winning
okay
g6 is not winning why is g6 not winning
because of course the king lacks shelter
and we can check from behind
so that idea is out rook g7 check also
not going to make any progress what are
you doing here if you go here
again check from behind no progress if
you go king g6
i can even take this and draw the game
so root g7
best you can do is repeat the position
okay so
rook g1 how can white win the first move
is rather obvious
king g6 but now what happens
tell me
tell me tell me tell me
yeah the black king can't run to the
right side but it could still
run to the left there's nothing
inherently wrong
with this idea
scott says rook f1 but this loses in the
same way that we've already seen
we just check take go king h7
chest king has a line of course black's
only move is king f8
then we see rook a8 check what else by
whites again
can't really move this king thanks to
this rook here
and if something like king h6 you just
get checked back to d6
so you have to give this check now king
e7
again you find your king sort of
tethered to this pawn
uh chess king's idea was to go king h6
went after king f7
rook a7 check and here
chess king suggested king e6
uh i don't know about king e6 i think i
would likely
come back to g8 when your best move
would be king g6 when after king f8 i'm
starting to get
a sense of deja vu here have we seen
this position
i think we have right i think we have i
played king f8 here
all you did was repeat king f7 stopping
the pawn
rook a7 king g8 g6 king f8 we're back to
where we started
so what is the winning idea for white in
this position
and i don't think the chatroom knows
this finally i'm stumping even the
superstars in the chat with
some theoretical knowledge that they
didn't have so white actually can win
this position
as i said what is the winning idea well
it's sort of the astounding
rook a check not astounding king e7 rook
g8 this is the winning point
white is going to be winning in this
position because
now no matter what black does king
h7 is the next move when after king f7
g6 comes with check and is defended
twice
this little blockade that we faced on
the g6 square
has been broken and no matter what
happens now
look at fate check king or not king e7
would be bad because if it takes g6
but just g7 here is winning the game
rook h2 king g8
and white is obviously winning with any
of the methods
that we've already seen okay just
to prove it rook a8 we go rook f4
and can build a bridge if nothing else
if nothing else
okay so
this sort of raises the question why
does this work here
and not anywhere else well let's jump
back to what we've already seen
which is this position and we looked at
the move rookie one
king e6 king f8 czech king g7
rookie 8. so this is the winning try
that you should be aware of and you
should keep in mind
so what's different about this position
compared to the last position black to
move and
draw you have to know this winning idea
if you're going for this rookie one line
it's important
why don't h2 check um yeah i don't want
to jump back rook h2 check would just
mean
king g7 when g6 would be
unstoppable
uh white's idea there is to put that one
file separation between the king and the
pawn so they can advance the pawn next
turn
transpose into something that is winning
so once again uh the chat room has it
right
the idea is to start checking from the
long side of the board with rook
a1 and this is going to be the idea that
allows black to draw the game
white is going to be able in many cases
to get the pawn
to the sixth rank but the point now
is that he's not going to be able to do
so in
a manner that actually wins the game
for example i actually don't even know
how to try to make progress here
rook d8 and i guess we can already just
start giving these checks
a8 e6 and believe it or not we've seen
this one
before we've seen this one
before with the rook on the long side of
the board the game
is going to be a draw king g6 for
example
or any of these passing moves i'll get
the job done
check here okay eight we've seen this
king d6 only way to try to make progress
now king f6
and this should look very very familiar
i think we've had this exact position
on the board so
questions about what we went over
tonight i covered a lot a lot a lot
of technical information uh hopefully
this gives you
a very near complete understanding of
these basic rook end games right now
hopefully you fully understand what the
loose senate is all about what the
philadelphus position
is all about there is a lot more to it
than you might have first
thought when when you first you know
learned what it was
any questions from you guys before we
call it a night here
all right no questions by chess king and
he asked this was basic of course when i
say basic i don't mean easy
i mean you know consisting
of the basic elements of an end game
right you can't get more basic than only
one pawn on the board
but one pawn is enough to cause immense
complications
um all right then that is gonna do it
for tonight's lecture if you're watching
live
head over to the twitch channel which is
hopefully
not broken um if you're watching the
youtube
video then that is going to do it for us
here tonight as always
thank you so much for watching my name
is caleb denby and i will see you
next time
you